اعلن جهاز مكافحه الارهاب في اقليم
كردستان العراق تعرض مطار اربيل الدولي
الى قصف بطائره مسيره وقال الجهاز في بيان
مقتضب ان طائره مسيره مفخخه استهدفت امس
قاعده التحالف الدولي ضد داعش داخل مطار
اربي الدولي من جهته قال مكتب رئيس
الوزراء العراقي ان الهجوم الذي وقع
بالقرب من مطار اربيل المدني ادى الى وقوع
قتل وجرحى وتعطيل عمل المطار تثير على
توقيتات الرحلات المدنيه واضاف يحيى رسول
الناطق العسكري باسم رئيس الوزراء العراقي
ان هذه العمليات هدفها الاضرار بمصالح
العراق وعلاقاته وارتباطاته الاقليميه
والدوليه وكانت فصائل المقاومه الاسلاميه
في العراق اعلنت هجومها بمسيره على قاعده
حرير التي تضم قوات عسكريه امريكيه في
اقليم كردستان شمالي
العراق